yeah so we have a set of principles we
don't write them down anywhere really I
mean they have been written down but we
didn't set out to write them down I
don't believe in like the whole like
mission statement thing but we just want
to build the simplest possible thing we
can that solves a real problem like
that's it for us we're always trying to
solve simple problems with simple
solutions and I think in general most
things are really easy in life things
get hard when you make them hard
but by default things are actually
pretty simple I think companies
unfortunately have been really good have
been built to make things very difficult
on themselves so we've kept our
companies small intentionally so we can
be a small company and do what small
companies can do which is move quickly
and come up with cool ideas and GEX
acute them quickly and don't sorts of
things and that's all around the
principle of just doing the simplest
possible thing we can to solve a real
problem one of the things I think it's
mixed up a lot companies are too
obsessed with innovation and not obsess
enough with usefulness so we're all
about like what can we do that's useful
not what's the latest technology what's
the crazy new thing but what's actually
useful and so that's really at the core
of what we're all about
well I think first and foremost were a
business now that's not always the case
because there are some that are
businesses you know like Google's very
successful of course and there's a few
others but for the most part a lot of
things that's going on in Silicon Valley
today are they're not businesses they
may be businesses but you're not really
business if you're just losing money or
if you're not charging for things we
we're a traditionalist company we charge
for things we have a product when we
sell it we also have some free stuff too
but we're all about selling things we're
all about making money and so I think
that's one of the things that sets us
apart but also we're not big into the
idea of get raising earth money early in
a company's history we're not big into
what's the latest technology that we
should be using we're not big into
staffing up quickly we're not big into
marketing the traditional marketing and
paying a PR firm 20 grand a month to get
the word out before you even start it
we're not big into that stuff we're big
into building really great products for
real customers who want to pay us money
to use those products and that's what
kind of what sets us apart I think quite
a bit